chi ha mai sta roba o continueranno a
uscire trofei vabbè lasciamo perdere a
tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a questo nuovo
video siamo subito al face quest
internet meme ios come non sono troppo
esperto di internet meme e sono serio
non è che sono espertissimi pro
proviamoci chiedo quante riesco a
riconoscerne soprattutto vediamo come
imeem e già sono ignoranti di loro e il
prof ei suoi sei ignorante di suo messo
insieme dovrà collezionare anche la
kascia divertente va bene allora se sono
un elfo innanzitutto salve qualcuno
riconosce ma cos'è un meme questo posso
entrare o no contrario che ovviamente
persa no io lo completa che strano era
così facile
qualcuno mi spiega il meme di prima
quando doveva essere mare gabbiani sole
ok vuoi gabbiani e il sole beh questo
l'ho capito il problema che non riesco a
fare nient'altro che questo il cartello
era cristallina la soluzione come ho
fatto non arrivarci prima ma cos'è sta
roba odio mia strambi cosa ti sorride ma
non ha capito niente perché lui non
rispondere iscrivi sull'ape con la penna
o io cliccato sulla penna pronta anno la
presa della corrente d'autore ha preso
la corrente strumenti si sua sorella
ecco e richiedono staccarla presa emma
[Musica]
a questa riformerà l'on
ho riconosciuto un meme tra tutti l'ho
riconosciuto let's go ok ok che me mera
questo scusate mito io non li conosco
sti maledettissimi me mio dio quanto
difficile
cosa mi rappresenta sta mica patata coi
denti
ok il gioco dal quoziente intellettivo
over the top
chiarissimo quello non so chi sia ma non
sono io perché ha la barba fammi capire
un attimo questo è un alce
adesso non lo è più cosa mi
rappresentava l'uccello stato fare sei
stato chiaro no me che devo tipo usare
ho trovato una cacca non posso cambiare
anche lui in qualche modo esattamente
così era più quello che dicevo che ti va
bene ma posso capire la madonna è va beh
direi no anche adesso ci avrei scommesso
questo è over gli attacchi your friends
e questa e dodge è messo proprio male
non capisco che gioco sia dalle carte
prova l'ha perso
va bene mi esplosa la carta addirittura
sicuramente ho vinto io sono come con
che fisica è finito il tavolo sotto gli
altri prova next io vi giuro tra tutti
me me che ho visto non riconosciuti 2
incrocio non li capisco
nell incontro di boxe più genuino della
storia micro diciamo ti premuto di più
urca vacca questa volta azzeccato misura
è giusto perfetto vai vai vai avanti
avanti per eco su piano reeves l'ho
riconosciuto sì è lui perché ha preso il
panino tipo matrix però non è un meme
che sia un meme ma va bene un meme
chissà quanto conosciuto credo e veloce
bellissimo bellissimo piace anche una
foto con lui adesso fatemelo a sfoggiare
così prendo le views bene ho finito o
che bello due bambini che scartano i
pacchi di natale non so che me ne sia io
conosco persone che sarebbero molto
contente di questo tipo
marco marino devo usare 64
[Musica]
sveglia chiarissimo che mente ecco cosa
mi rappresenta sto bene devo devo
ingigantire la seria ecco esatto madonna
che botta a posto
next a questo lo conosco questo volevo
fare una volta in un video poi ho detto
vabbè lasciamo perdere che è meglio
praticamente non è tanto marylin manson
notizie più che altro se il pallino
finisce per toccare i bordi ti prendi un
infarto credo che tutti conoscete sta
roba
ma non è un meme in realtà non è stata
non è stata esattamente la mia reazione
quando l'ho giocato la prima volta ve lo
giuro
[Applauso]
il gatto deve fare qualcosa che facevano
sarebbe lì impossibile torello cliccato
devo avere una reazione per questo no la
risposta è no avanti che me me che me e
me chi ha fatto sto gioco che mi ha
visto nella sua vita non ho mai visto
sto bene ma cos'è
ok ho trovato una cacata faccio schifo
ho già comprato in trovare merda sono
bravissimi deve fare qualcosa il tappeto
no a ok perfetto
questo potrebbe essere un problema però
le donne non lo fanno con the fantasy
sto gioco le donne non fanno la cacca
fatto va bene guadagna soldi
semplicemente giocando tranquillo lo
faccio io devo guardare ste pubblicità
per forza questo non mi fa andare avanti
nei livelli capito qual è il problema
avete freddo ragazzi volete un po del
mio piumino volete un po di legna
nessuno effetto il fuoco morti i
personaggi basta scrivermi buon
capodanno ad onna siamo a maggio a ecco
[Musica]
c'è un limite a tutto ragazzi il
programmatore visto gioco perché c'è uno
che lo programma non è che nasce dall
albero avrà una certa età ti sei
sviluppato dentro il cervello non le
voglio le scarpe alieni a queste obama
cosa mi sembra il discorso più equo da
fare un alieno tieni ha giustamente gli
alieni si divertono quei carcere perché
non sanno che in realtà fanno male next
alla modo chiesta gnocca non è andata
proprio come speravo tengo premuto sulla
borsetta che imita regalo neanche così
vaga ma ci deve essere un altro modo ad
ewood sul mare sulla tipo grazie degli
indizi se non sarei mai arrivato
proviamo ok ma il caso ho visto ma dio
mio
va bene andiamo il cavallo che
sussurrava le bambine però non va bene
temo premuto sulla tia
ok devo rifarlo a più piccolo ok chi è
chiarissimo guarda ragazzi per ora
concludo qui trophies questi internet
mems continuiamo nel prossimo facciamo
un episodio 2 perché mi piace veramente
ogni volta che faccio trophies questo
non ci vuole una settimana in terapia
per riprendermi però va bene spero che
vi sia piaciuto ragazzi come se vi piace
anche al risparmio descrizione
iscrivetevi al canale ci vediamo guarda
nessuna disgrazia è peggio di quello che
ha appena giocato quindi va bene così
beh ragazzi
[Musica]